[音楽]
ラジコン空撮ばっかり会えずやり続けで31年目になりました
皆さん呼ぶドローンドローンとってますけどもたくさんプロペラついているのが
ドローンだと思ってる
桜が多いですよねラジコン機ドクター無人航空機のことドローンと言いまして
ですからドローンというものを活用して31年
ただから空撮をやってきました
まあ私の人生好きなことばっかり終えずーっと若いころからやってきて最初はもう
スノーボードから初めてスノーボードがまだスキー場ですべちゃいけないと言われて
いるころから
スノーボード普及させようと思って一生懸命頑張っていっ
やっとながらオリンピックで正式種目となり
そこのコーディネーション全部やらせてもらいーそして2006年のトリノ
オリンピック悪い
イタリアから4日間の生中継の
a スノーボードの競技解説をがやらせてもらいました
それをやりながらすでに姫
ラジコンヒロ負担封殺もずっとやってたわけですね
結局自分の g 生好きなことしかやっていない
好きなことやってるから一年中働いても何もつたくないん
今今年
半数半年で
休んだ日日2日ぐらいかな
でこれから半年後まもすけ中だけ高いっぱいですけどもまぁ10日間は奴にはないです
ね年間でね
で好きなことばっかりやってるんでこれは僕らにとって
もはや休日であると
好きなことばっかりやってるんだ
ねあれん
うんどちらについておこういう方が2になっていると
だって好きなのでやって内部飛ばすことが好きだからね
でラジコンをずーっとやり続けて
まあ
一気1000万ぐらいのヘルプたーーーーを買ってですねそして何球かあってやるん
ですけどもまぁ仕事なんてあるわけないですよ
その時代にで年間に喧嘩3件ぐらいの空撮の地雷があるんですよ
でも2000万が3000万かけたんですよ
そんなもう儲かろう日はねぇですよ
で受けがは同社この20年も20何年も飯くれないでやってこられたのかと
これは
通常だとかへ去ったらもうその事業をやめなさいともうちゃんと働いてもいいよって
言われるんですよ
でもスノーボードもずっとやってきたり好きなことばっかり手え出し500ても絶対
これはいけるはずだと思いつつ
やり続けてきたんですけども
まあこれを助けてくれたのは農家の方だったんですよね
で自分にその技術があるんだったら農薬散布をやってみないかと
その技術で散歩行ってみないかっておいて農薬三平リフターを
ずっと橋ついててまあ初日間ぐらいの農薬散布
この時期に得たお金が年間1000万ぐらいなんですよ
初神楽で年間1000万ぐらいもらえるんですよそれがずーっとやれたので空撮って
いうのをそのお金を貯めながらやってこれるわけですね
そうでないとやれるわけはないですよね
それはずっとやり続けて今までやってきました
で数年前に何か起きた
マルチコプターというプロペラついてターンをこのまあマルチコプターって言うんです
が僕らはね
でそれを2機で行って撮影したんですけども数年前首相官邸にドローンが墜落しました
やっとこれからだと思った好きです
やっと20何年さんもう207発明頑張ってた時に
小艦艇に心ないパイロットがそこいうことをする
マラソン大会で墜落をする
ドロン=悪のイメージ
ですよねでした今ではどうでしょう
ドローンの専門学校があるんです
そしてドローンが国が認めて認定証を出し始めたんです
もはや専門学校なって当時から考えたアップの集まり伸ばしていた
そうなんですよそれがあれから数年たってだけで
論が専門学校で教えるようになり
2020年の東京オリンピックではドローンを活用して8型映像で世界の区立 ok を
買っていた時です
今
ドローンの国土交通省航空局に申請されている数チームは17,0002です
1万7千人の方まあその中に数名の方も書いてあるで約2万人以上の方がドロン
パイロットとして待っています
僕はこれからがんばんなきゃいけない何なのかったらドロンパイロトって名前を
このように広めたのはもう僕でして名づけ終えでもあるわけですと論破いると当時だ
から開くの
トップですよね
これ以上の茜とやつをやればもう出てこれらへんだと思うくらい
ドローンパイロットという名前をつけて出てきたもんですから
これを先ほど番組はありますけども
doronpa いる時はひろちとこれ一番選手ねー
ドローン操縦士っていう名前で行く予定だったんですよ
でこれはまた目だももへんもドローンはもう全部はもう悪をやり続けですよもういい
ことしかもうないはずだと
よしドローンた色というか doronpa いる時はヒロチョして出てきたわけです
よね
これから中のがドローンのイメージをどんどんどんどん変えていって何ら今ドローン
足りないかった
何がと言うんでしょう
素晴らしい映像を撮れる揺れない映像が撮れる
素晴らしいことできますよねそれボラ年間300日ロケやってます
年間フライト数が2000フライト
もう無事故です事故など越したことないんですよ
だけでも落ちますよこれ着たいわ
飛んでるもんですもん
有名な大きな旅客機も落ちてます
アメリカで上げている宇宙に行く飛行機もあるロケットも爆発せます
僕らみたいなあのドローンとやってもが落ちないわけがないんですよ
落ちますどうした浮き輪に線フライト年間やっていた落ちないのか
それは今日落ちないようにしよう
明日落ちないようにしようと思って定期点検をだとかいろんなことをやるけど
バッテリーを調べたりとか
天候を見て今日は絶対飛ばしくださいっても絶対いたしませんってことあるんです
風吹いダブないですね
一度のミスが僕の人生を終わりにして yahoo トップニュース乗るんですお母ん
ねえまぁその辺のと論破いるでをしたらいいですよ私がも招致ましょう
きたら間違いなくあの有名な某テレビに出た
それは無いだうんもう撮れ事故だけを絶対残しちゃいけないと思って
そういう点検をしながらやってるわけですよね
そして年間300日をロケをやり
テレビコマーシャルで今出ている日本で写っているあこれらじこんだな
ドローンだなぁと思ってうちの7割ぐらいは打ちの快晴だっていますですからほとんど
の犬に言ってます
北海道のほとんど帰っておりませんだけど北海道で生まれ育って北海道のこのだ
市が僕の技術を育てたいったいどういうことなんですか
それはとばせる環境があるからです
言っちゃうか否かなんですほっどこを飛ばしても怒られないです
東京23区や無理なんです飛ばせ立つ警察に通報されるんです
すぐ逮捕されるんですよ航空法違反ででもこの北海道でしょ
航空法に触れないより練習すればちょっと郊外いけば練習できるんです
ですから北海道の札幌や旭川の出資のスキーあはオリンピックでてますね
帯広の方なるとスケートの選手が出てますドローンパイロット北海道の田舎もしくは
郊外なぁかにいるんです
こんなこと言っちゃ怒られるけど都会に有名なパルといないです
この者上手だなあとまた出身土地等の多い中ですかって聞いた方言
その個くらい田舎にいる僕がずーっと撮影をして空を見ながら周りを環境見ながら
飛ばしています
空気が読めるんです
読めないの一つだけでます
家庭の空気を
これは難しいいろんなとこに気圧配置が香る区
1回ビルの2階に出す
これは31年ドロンパいるとやつもあったが読めないん
突然変わる
突然液晶上曲でだろそこダメなんですね
そうやってやってるんですけどもまぁ僕らはこれから2020年の東京オリンピックの
パイロットとを育成とか
それとがええええ緊急ものを運んだりとか
人命救助したりとか
いろんなことでドローンがこれから何をしなきゃいけないかというのは貢献とが足り
なかったデストロに
ですよねまだ誰も助けてないんです
誰も殺してもいないですねうちは自重
なのにフォローしても何もいないドローンにいろいろ規制をかけられてたんですよ
どうですが家で使ってもの
ナイフ包丁何の認定証ありますがお母さん絞ってる時何認定証もないんですよ
もっともダブないものを使ってんですけどドローンはまで一度も人もこうしてね日本で
はちょっとけがをしたというと
ですからこれは何なのかったら将来的にイオンなく性能が上がってくると何かに使わ
れる可能性があるわけで当然ながら
農薬散布があって二水をまいているうちはいいですけど違うものを投下されると大変な
ことになります一瞬にしてドローンがこの世からなくなりますね
でいろいろ
戦争だと変わらない使っているようなドローンが今度は平和のとして違うものとして
使われようとまぁカメラもそうですね
車もそう夏もともとそうですねドローンも同じように次はは日本はそういう武器使った
ことは一度もないだけですね
無人航空機っていうものですから我々はやらなきゃいけないな貢献度なんですよ
公共をどうしていくかということに対してやっぱりパイロットの技術っての必要なん
です
指二本のいいましたね僕ね指2本だけ自分のことしか信用できないんです全くそうで
gps を使ったらあんまりしないわけですよ
指日本の技術と自分の木し思考だけを見てるんですね
ですから
ここのトレーニングだけなんですよ
で難しいこと言ってるわけで何でもねラジコン飛ばす討論を飛ばすことって指2本です
から2本3本4本5本てを足を動かしてわけだよね
たった2本
うちの親父に言われました
地に足のついた仕事をしないといけません
本当はパイロットなりたかったんですチン足につかなかったですやめろちゃいました
今ちゃんと言いごま持っています地に足がついたしますよどうせも祝汁スティック
ワープの技術中のを今僕らを教えなきゃいけない
これが僕はもし20代とか
30代だったらどうしてでしょう
教えるわけがない
盗まれたら困るが技術でも椋箚記
55歳とてましたよねもうあれから1年経ってついに56歳になってしまった
確実にせずとしますもうこうなると教えたくてしょうがないん
何なのかったらこの技術を伝えてこれを跡を継いでくれベストを作るしかないんですよ
この技術を伝えていくしかない立った日本の技術
今ドローンを売ってるのはカタログを見ると
買ったその日から飛ばせますよ買ったその日から
パイロットですよ封殺ができます使ってますりっ子音です1つ間違ったら事故起きるん
ですですよねそうやって自己を着てきたんです
僕だってずーっと年間実戦フライトやって
300日の受けやって言って事故起きたことがねえ
そして航空法が支えられて僕らがどんどんどんどん
規制変わってきていろんな承認証となきゃいけない使うたらなきゃいけで難しいことは
どんどんどんどん
壁が出てくるでもこれを克服していかなきゃいけない
でもこれをずっとほっとくとどんどんまで規制も厳しくなるって2020年東京
オリンピックやってくる
これさえなくなります
で僕は立ち上がったんですよね
スノーボードの時のようにいつかは
オリンピック種目となり遊びだと思われた種目はスポーツ詰まっていく
それをずっとやってきてもうゼロからの本当にダメなところからスタートしました
ドローもまた同じようなこと僕らやっていると思います
全くダメだったところからゼロからやったって全然いいじゃないですか
もうこの年齢だもう教えるしかね
全国各地でプロパイロット認定会となっています
これは南の国からも許可ももらっていいねぇ
性にも貼ってことねでも日本の指だけの技術が一番救われるんですよ
今の航空機てどうですか車とどうですかこれから自動運転化してきますよね
座ってボタンを押したら目的地に着きます飛行機もボタン一つをしたらパリまで行くん
ですオートパイロットで
だけどもそこの空万徳に座るのは
公安委員会で沿った免許を持った人来てボタンを押すんですよね
それを
そして1億円ぐらいかけたパイロット養成さすがオートパイロットのスイッチを入れる
んですよね
決して僕がそこに座れるわけじゃないんですよオートパイロットがあってもドローンは
どうして
gps をレッサーがあなたの飛ばせますよって行っちゃったんでしょうかね
ここが違ったと思ったんですよ
もうマニュアル操縦で十分飛ばせる人が gps の設置を入れると
それでこそ安全フライトができると思っていますそしてその技術を伝えるために全国
各地で今プロパイロット認定会してスクールをしながら検定会があります
北は北海道南は沖縄まで毎月のように
次のた色と育成してその校で育成してパールとできたところが僕らがヘッド
ハンティングをして東京五輪を飛ばそうじゃないかとやっています
じゃ
どこが後府堺方じゃっ
させた田舎ばっかりだず
東京23区200名ぐらい打って首相からね例えば
でも沖縄であると
15名などに4名合格すると
やっぱり環境なんですよでもこれからっていうのは屋内飛行場が用意されたりとか
僕らみたいなを教えるたちがいるオーラって全然を教えられてみなかった
ラジコンクラブに入った時から一番センスのないパイロットとしてクラブ員に思われて
いました
全然うまく何年
全然上手くなんで飛行時のまんだけど毎日カバーリングしている
ホバリングしてるから耳くんフラグのマグ仲間から受け側くると沿わせないと言われ
です真ん中で人とっているからどっか行ってくれております
したら毎日朝
河原橋の人で練習するんです被告はもうラジコンクラブ飛行場に行けないんです
そしてセンスがない僕は今毎日のトレーニングしました
毎日毎日トレーニングてやっとここまでこれたんです動力吸う奴にかなわないんですよ
ですからプロペラと認定会というに当てて大隠しないようなセンスの無い人見ると
no 恋県のおれオレを感じるの
そしてパパ甘いそう
だめだなあれ
だってクラブでう練習してて選手に買ったやつ今はもうやってないもの
でも選手もなかった人間枚まだ猫努力てやっている
ですから我々は私はこれから2022東京に向かって優秀なパイルと一致性をこれから
も作ってやっていたいと思います
本当に今日あ徹底ここに僕に出させたらいいなと思ってませんでした
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]